I want to look forward obviously the new
minister is lined up with a new regime
of the royalty tell us about the new
minister and how he will deal day-to-day
with the king and with the deputy Crown
Prince as you said the new minister is
part of the inner circle of the deputy
Crown Prince and that's why for example
we don't expect any fundamental change
in oil policies he's gonna continue to
defend the Saudi market share the change
will be more on the domestic side you
see the oil ministry's name has changed
to the energy and industry and Mineral
Resources and this part this is part of
the vision you know to turn Aramco
itself from an oil and gas company into
an energy industrial conglomerate behind
you Allah in Dubai is you claimed and
beautiful D IFC building folks you can
see it in the gorgeous white marble
behind mr. Shaheen I'm told that Riyadh
wants to Redux this they want to open up
their society create a D IFC equivalent
and become more financially part of
global capitalism is there any bet that
the traditional royal family can do that
well they're trying to they're they're
setting up their King Abdullah financial
district in Riyadh but they're that this
project in particular is dodged with
with a lot of problems and that was one
of the aims of the vision is trying to
like you to reboot it but of course you
know as you said you know Dubai is
well-established as a well established
financial center in the Middle East
others have tried to do that Doha tried
Abu Dhabi tried but you know they
haven't been able to unseat Dubai let
alone that challenge that you refer to
domestically on you know for the Saudi
society so it's it's it's a tall
mountain to climb and you are asked you
ask yourself how many financial hubs
does the Middle East need at least at
this stage how much is he a puppet of
Mohammed bin Salman though he did go to
the April meeting in Doha and agree to a
freeze only to you turn at the last
minute yeah so now deputy conference
appears to have a greater say in the oil
and oil policy men
Jamie who was replaced during the
weekend was negotiating the fries deal
with OPEC and non-opec members and then
before the meeting the deputy Crown
Prince told us in an interview that
still his position is still the same
unless everybody agrees there will be no
freeze and then when the meeting started
in Doha on Sunday we all saw what
happened and we also what the we all saw
what the Russians and the Venezuelans
counterparts said that mr. Nyami did not
have the authority to negotiate in Doha
which points to the the rising influence
of the depth of conference forget allah
Sheheen's thank you so much our Allah
Sheen with Bloomberg News in Dubai